[Aplausos]
[Música]
amigos amigas presta mucha atención a
estas sorprendentes declaraciones de la
primera ministra de suecia la líder
socialdemócrata magdalena' anderson la
primera ministra sueca dice que la
integración de inmigrantes ha fallado y
ha alimentado el crimen de bandas la
integración ha sido demasiado pobre al
mismo tiempo que hemos tenido una gran
inmigración la sociedad ha sido
demasiado débil los recursos para la
policía y los servicios sociales han
sido demasiado pobres se ha permitido
que la segregación llegue tan lejos que
tenemos sociedades paralelas en suecia
vivimos en el mismo país pero en
realidades completamente diferentes
magdalena' anderson primera ministra de
suecia a ver que una líder
socialdemócrata que además está en el
poder haga declaraciones como estas
sobre la inmigración no es algo nada
pero que nada común algo muy serio tiene
que estar pasando en suecia no os parece
a qué se refiere exactamente la primera
ministra porque el tema de la
inmigración ha pasado a estar en el
candelero en uno de los países más
abiertos del mundo que es exactamente lo
que está pasando en suecia pues bien
veámoslo por cierto antes de seguir un
apunte te has preguntado alguna vez cómo
ganar dinero y cuánto en los grandes
gigantes tecnológicos como apple
microsoft alfabeto o amazon y ojo que no
es una pregunta menor hablamos de
empresas cuyo valor combinado supera los
75 millones de dólares más de 5 veces el
pib de un país como españa hablamos de
empresas que han sustituido a los
grandes grupos industriales y petroleros
como las empresas más grandes del mundo
así que la pregunta es cómo lo han
conseguido amigos amigas creo que la
respuesta puede sorprenderlos así que si
queréis saber más no os perdáis el
último vídeo de si lo hubiera sabido el
canal de información financiera de mucho
activos con el que participamos os dejo
el enlace en la descripción dicho esto
continuemos
cifras de pánico
[Música]
presta mucha atención a las siguientes
cifras porque estoy seguro que a más de
uno os van a sorprender y mucho en 2021
se registraron en suecia
335 tiroteos que se saldaron con 47
personas fallecidas sí vale si nos estás
viendo desde eeuu o de américa latina'
estos numerosos pueden parecer casi una
broma casi casi una arcadia feliz si
tenemos en cuenta la diferencia de
población el dato es infinitamente mejor
que el que cada año registra eeuu o
prácticamente cualquier país
latinoamericano por ejemplo en 2020 tan
solo en los eeuu los homicidios y
tiroteos le costaron la vida a más de 23
mil personas hablamos de escenarios
completamente diferentes sin embargo
amigos amigas para los cánones europeos
los datos de suecia sí que son
llamativos
suecia es el país de toda europa donde
más están creciendo los crímenes
relacionados con armas de fuego y tiene
una de las tasas de fallecidos más altas
por ejemplo mientras que suecia tiene
una media de 4 muertes por millón de
habitantes al año por armas de fuego la
media europea se sitúa en 16 además a
diferencia del resto de europa la
tendencia en suecia es creciente
un dato curioso todo esto supone por
ejemplo que la probabilidad de que un
hombre de entre 15 y 29 años recibe un
disparo es diez veces más alta en suecia
que en alemania suecia a la cabeza en
tiroteos mortales en europa según
informe en menos de una década suecia ha
superado a italia y en los países de
europa del este en tener el mayor número
de tiroteos mortales en europa pero esto
no es todo en 2019 por ejemplo se
registraron 260 delitos con explosivos
en toda suecia un incremento del 60 por
ciento respecto al año anterior hablamos
de bombas y artefactos explosivos que
suelen explotar en espacios públicos
sobre todo en los exteriores de
urbanizaciones de apartamentos y en
pequeños negocios sorprendidos pues si a
todo esto le sumamos también que este
país tiene las tasas de violaciones y
violencias sexuales más altas de toda
europa y que además los delitos de odio
contra minorías como por ejemplo las
personas lgtb también están al alza
entonces tenemos el combo casi perfecto
es evidente que en su decía hay un
problema
[Música]
eso sí sorprendentemente si nos fijamos
en todos los delitos la tasa de
criminalidad de suecia no es
particularmente elevada está en la media
europea es decir que el país nórdico
tiene sobre todo un problema con las
armas los explosivos la violencia sexual
y los ataques a minorías o dicho de otra
forma en el contexto europeo suecia
tiene fundamentalmente un problema con
los crímenes violentos y de corte sexual
y esto esto es lo que explica que los
suecos sean precisamente y por mucha
diferencia los europeos que más
preocupados están con el crimen para
ellos es ya la primera preocupación y
esto también es lo que explican las
palabras de la primera ministra
magdalena anderson que vimos al comienzo
de este vídeo fijaos
ahora bien llegados a este punto la
pregunta que seguro seguro muchos os
estáis haciendo es qué demonios está
pasando en suecia aquí el [ __ ] se
explica está semejante ola de violencia
pues bien la mayoría de los tiroteos y
las explosiones en este país tienen que
ver con bandas del crimen organizado
en el país nórdico ocho de cada diez
tiroteos tienen que ver con bandas
criminales el problema que más inquietud
está causando es que más de la mitad el
53% de los sentenciados a prisión
nacieron en el extranjero un porcentaje
que si tenemos en cuenta tanto las
personas nacidas en el extranjero como
las que pertenecen a una segunda
generación se eleva hasta casi el 90 por
ciento de los sospechosos de
protagonizar tiroteos
[Música]
queridos amigos amigas lógicamente con
este vídeo no pretendemos señalar a
nadie por su origen todo lo contrario
sabéis que en visual político nos gustan
cosas como la libertad de circulación y
que pensamos que los movimientos
migratorios son un poderoso motor de
prosperidad siempre y cuando las cosas
pues se hagan bien claro está por eso
con este vídeo queremos poner sobre la
mesa a algunos de los factores que
pueden dificultar una integración
efectiva y que son lo que explican que
la situación en sociedad pueda ser
radicalmente distinta a la de países
como australia nueva zelanda o incluso
los eeuu recordáis el titular que
veíamos al principio del vídeo la
primera ministra sueca dice que la
integración de inmigrantes ha fallado ya
ha alimentado el crimen de bandas pues
exactamente eso así que para entender
toda esta situación tenemos que hacernos
unas cuantas preguntas de verdad el
aumento de los crímenes violentos en
suecia es sólo culpa de los inmigrantes
y responsabilidad quien aquí el poder
público es decir los políticos en qué ha
fallado si es que lo ha hecho el sistema
de suecia pues bien veámoslo
[Música]
única culpable
amigos amigas en suecia la delincuencia
relacionada con la inmigración tiene un
componente clave a la hora de unir ambos
fenómenos la exclusión social pero un
momento antes de que algunos otros ponga
el grito en el cielo no en este vídeo no
os vamos a contar la típica historia de
que la delincuencia está justificada
exclusivamente por la pobreza y que por
tanto la solución es dar muchas más
ayudas y subsidios de todo tipo este es
un tema muy complejo en el que vamos a
poder encontrar muchas causas y en el
que desde luego la pobreza juega un
papel muy pero que muy importante pero
amigos amigas si algo sobra en suecia
son precisamente las ayudas y los
subsidios públicos y de hecho aunque
pueda resultar contradictorio este
exceso de fondos públicos puede haber
contribuido a explicar buena parte de
este tsunami de exclusión y crimen que
ha experimentado el país escandinavo al
menos bajo los cánones europeos y ojo
esto no es algo que digamos nosotros y
esto es algo que hasta la primera
ministra socialdemócrata parece empezar
a tener muy pero que muy claro
[Música]
en suecia la población inmigrante recibe
enormes cantidades de ayudas públicas
especialmente si son solicitantes de
asilo pero si hay un subsidio que
destaca por encima del resto es la
asignación por hijo un subsidio que no
es exclusivo para los inmigrantes en
1982 cuando suecia comenzó a
experimentar tasas muy bajas de
natalidad se creó un subsidio y ofrece
suculentos ingresos a las familias por
tener hijos
[Música]
y no no hablamos de un cheque-bebé al
uso hablamos de una subvención que toda
persona residente en legal en suecia
cobra desde el mes siguiente del
nacimiento hasta aquí el niño cumple los
16 años de edad e incluso bajo ciertas
circunstancias esta ayuda se puede
extender hasta los 20 años y que ofrece
el estado sueco por cada hijo pues
básicamente una subvención de 1250
coronas al mes 12 120 euros o 126
dólares y sabéis que la población
inmigrante tiene de media muchos más
hijos así que este subsidio les favorece
particularmente pero además de éste hay
muchos otros que también los favorecen
especialmente
hablamos por ejemplo de las ayudas a los
alquileres para familias numerosas o las
ventajas en el acceso a la vivienda
pública o los subsidios directos en el
caso de los solicitantes de asilo entre
muchos otros programas pero la pregunta
que muchos seguros estáis haciendo en
este preciso momento es haber enrique
que tiene todo esto de malo que tiene
que ver con el problema que estamos
abordando en este vídeo pues más ni
menos que todas estas ayudas tienen
consecuencias directas sobre el mercado
laboral digamos que muchas personas
terminan haciendo de las ayudas públicas
algo más que un recurso transitorio y
ojo insisto no lo decimos nosotros lo
dicen por ejemplo los datos de empleo y
además lo dicen claramente
la peor parte se la llevan las mujeres
ya que muchos de estos subsidios es
incentivan su incorporación al mercado
laboral y su integración social que ya
de por sí puede resultar complicada en
algunas culturas por ejemplo según
eurostat en suecia la tasa de empleo de
las mujeres nacidas en el extranjero es
casi 20 puntos inferior a la tasa de las
mujeres que han nacido en el país por
otro lado estas ayudas fomentan también
una falsa estabilidad económica que hace
que muchos beneficiarios
busquen trabajos regulares precisamente
para no perder estos subsidios esto es
gasolina para crear redes informales que
terminan favoreciendo la creación y el
desarrollo de grupos criminales y bandas
en eeuu y nueva zelanda los inmigrantes
tienen tasas de empleo más altas que la
población nacida en el país en el caso
de austral y canadá la diferencia es de
apenas 3,4 y 17 puntos respectivamente
pues bien eso decía la diferencia es de
casi 15 puntos es decir hablamos de una
situación completamente distinta y eso
eso no es todo
al reducir las tasas de empleo y
disuadir a muchos inmigrantes de buscar
empleos formales a tiempo completo
también se reduce su grado de
integración y se merma su contacto con
el resto de la sociedad y si a ello le
sumamos las políticas de vivienda
pública el resultado es un cóctel
perfecto para la gestación de retos un
ambiente particularmente propicio para
el desarrollo de las bandas de esta
forma se calcula que tan solo en
estocolmo hay unas 60 bandas del crimen
organizado operando a lo largo y ancho
de toda la ciudad la pregunta es tiene
todo esta solución qué consecuencias
pueden tener estas políticas exactamente
qué es lo que quiere hacer ahora la
socialdemócrata suecia pues amigos
amigas como tantas veces ocurren las
malas políticas no sólo conllevan malos
resultados y en ocasiones también
conllevan malas respuestas o al menos
respuestas insuficientes
del blanco al negro sin rumbo claro
de repente suecia está cambiando y lo
está haciendo a pasos acelerados incluso
aunque gobierno siga en manos de
políticos socialdemócratas lo está
haciendo en la buena dirección bueno ese
ya es otro debate el caso es que si
hasta hace poco suecia era un ejemplo de
puertas abiertas ahora la reacción
social y política puede terminar
alimentando movimientos antagónicos y
hostiles hacia esa realidad por ejemplo
si en el año 2015 de suecia se convirtió
con diferencia y ni el país que más
refugiados sirios acogió en relación a
su población ahora apenas siete años
después los titulares que podéis
encontrar en google si buscáis
inmigración y suecia son muy pero que
muy diferentes
incluso suecia no quiere más inmigrantes
ahora el propio gobierno socialdemócrata
va a poner en marcha una nueva ley de
inmigración supuestamente para atajar la
causa de todos los problemas la nueva
ley de inmigración sueca endurece la
residencia permanente para refugiados y
visitantes con esta nueva ley las
personas llegadas del extranjero ya no
lo tendrán tan fácil para llegar o para
recibir las ayudas públicas tampoco será
posible conseguir un permiso de trabajo
sin tener un contrato y además se
requerirá un mínimo de tres años
viviendo en suecia para conseguir la
residencia permanente y también se
pedirá una justificación de ingresos
mínimos mensuales de 810 euros y en sí
mismo no dice nada diferente a la de
otros muchos países europeos pero la
cuestión es que en este caso el objetivo
último es que lleguen muchos menos
inmigrantes por supuesto ese no es el
problema soy de ciudad tiene muchos
menos inmigrantes que países como
australia nueva zelanda o canadá pero da
igual esta es la respuesta que quiere
dar el gobierno socialdemócrata the
magdalene anderson lo que supone un giro
de 180 grados en la política del país
eso sí lo que de momento no cambiará es
el abultado régimen de ayudas y
subvenciones y tampoco las políticas de
vivienda para evitar la formación de
guetos más bien todo lo contrario el
gobierno socialdemócrata de magdalena
anderson quiere poner aún más dinero
sobre la mesa sin prestar atención a
cuestiones tan relevantes como el nivel
de empleo o emprendimiento tiene la
población llegada del extranjero dos
factores que junto a la educación
resultan claves para promover la
integración
no nos equivoquemos el problema no es el
número de inmigrantes que hay en suecia
el problema está sobre todo en el
ineficiente e inadecuado régimen de
ayudas y subsidios de todo tipo al final
con este tipo de cambios se corre el
riesgo de criminalizar a toda la
población extranjera sin conseguir
realmente nada y que queréis que os diga
que la respuesta del gobierno sea
reconocer el problema culpar a la
inmigración a hacer cambios legales para
que lleguen menos extranjeros al país y
querer regar luego con más dinero los
que ya están pues no parece algo muy
sensato por muchos votos que las
subvenciones puedan darle al gobierno
porque amigos amigas el problema de su
de ciudadanía son los inmigrantes ni
tampoco la falta de gasto social de
hecho en este país el gasto social
medido en términos de pib es por ejemplo
un 52 por ciento más alto que en
australia lo cierto es que todo apunta a
que el problema es exactamente el
contrario pero llegados hasta aquí turno
para ti con todo lo que has visto crees
que el verdadero problema de suecia es
la inmigración o por el contrario es más
bien el resultado de unas malas
políticas públicas dejan a dos por aquí
abajo tus comentarios y ya sabéis si
este vídeos ha resultado interesante no
olvidéis darle al aek y suscribirnos a
visual política para estar al tanto de
todas las novedades una vez más muchas
gracias por estar ahí un saludo y hasta
la próxima
[Música]